I'm a celebrity
he's a celebrity get him out of here
Matt Hancock has announced that he is
going to stand down as an MP at the next
election he's a Suffolk MP he of course
had the whip taken away from him because
he went to appear on I'm a celebrity get
me out of here uh the uh sunac
government decided that was not
compatible with being a conservative uh
and so he's currently a MP with that
affiliation in the comments he will now
uh Stand Down says there's no need to
restore the whip he has just on his
Twitter feed uh published a letter
saying that he does not intend to stand
for the conservatives at the next
election and essentially he talked a lot
about his own career he's been a cabinet
minister for many of those years he was
culture secretary before of course he
did that iconic stinters Health
secretary when uh he was one of the key
figures who took the nation through the
pandemic and now he talks about how he
believes that the conservative party is
in a bit of a hole essentially he says
that we've got to reconnect with the
public that we serve and how previously
he thought the only way he could do that
was 3 Parliament but now he wants to try
something new to try and connect with
people I'm not quite sure what he's
getting at Matt Hancock the chat show
host who knows possibly mayor of London
bid you could see him trying to reinvent
himself but he's decided to stand down
uh as an MP we sort of have an inkling
that this might be coming not least from
the extremely strong denials that he'd
be standing down uh that he gave a
couple of weeks ago but yeah I think
that there is just a sense now that as a
figure he's unlikely to be welcomed back
into the bosom of the conservative party
so he's getting ahead of that and saying
that he doesn't need to be because he's
not going to stand as a Toria but that
means that he's still staying as an MP
until the end of of the the parliament
so people who he's their constituents MP
will still have a constituency MP
absolutely and he's very explicit that
um he will continue he says of course to
represent all by constituents between
now and the next election which doesn't
have to be until the back end of 2024 we
don't know when the next general
election uh will be so he'll be uh
sticking around uh on our screens for
some time to come but a hint of wanting
to do something bigger outside politics
certainly outside Parliament not
necessarily unconnected with politics
some concern in his letter for the fate
of the conservative party critics I
think we'll say that he's one of the
reasons that there is uh some trouble
with the conservative party and in
conservative uh fortunes for now one of
the most high profile figures in this
Parliament uh was the controversial
Health secretary during the pandemic who
then uh became even more known to
Millions uh by appearing on a celebrity
TV program